the last thing we need to complete this
is to know how to convert back and forth
between beers okay so the one I'm going
to concentrate on excuse me is is this
guy I need it to be bigger we're going
to just talk about converting between
late I'll start you off for converting
between areas but you just need to be
aware of this so we're gonna draw some
charts okay so with me and I hope this
reeks of bells I want you to draw a
diagram that looks like this
oh yeah you should be able to fit all of
the picture paper just like I am no no
you can start it you can start it and
this should be yeah one two three four
okay because we had for our common units
of length we had four of them okay so in
order again you've got kilometers meters
centimeters and okay so yes yes here are
arrows right so for example if I said to
you okay I ran 5,000 meters on the
weekend which I did okay if you wanted
to turn that number into kilometers what
are you gonna do to that 5,000 number to
turn it into the equivalent you're gonna
divide by a thousand okay so think about
this from meters to kilometers your
units are bigger so you have less of
them does that make sense you have a
thousand times less in the same way if I
were to go the other way
beaters are much smaller unit so you've
got lots of them so instead of dividing
by a thousand you multiply by a thousand
yeah now you can see where the rest of
this is gonna go right if I said to you
okay I measured my height is a hundred
and seventy eight centimeters right so
if I want to convert that into meters
again the units are bigger so the less
of them so I'm gonna divide by quadrant
which means if I went the other way and
said okay here's a number beetus what's
that in centimeters I'm gonna multiply
by hundred last one if I say okay why my
hair length is you know 32 millimeters
how am I gonna do to that number to
convert it to centimeters divided by 10
which means correspondingly if I want to
go from a bigger unit to a small
you know a little multiplied by ten okay
so the handy you could put on that one
is length conversion whoops
leave good budget now don't start this
on your page because you won't have I
mean if you draw in the same size as me
you would have space on the board of
this page but you can either do this in
your book or on the back of this page
that was late conversion what about area
conversion okay now don't start this
just watch me do it okay I'm gonna do
the beginning now if I said let's just
think about meters squared and said of
meters square okay just think about that
for a second in fact if you've got a
ruler there if you've got a ruler I want
you to have in front of you just so you
can see what we're thinking of okay now
if I said to you okay I have one square
meter this is a meter so 100 centimeters
this way so if I were to draw one edge
of my square meter it would be other
edge of my square do ya do you see if I
did a bunch of like here's one space
center but you see that you've got your
ruler in front of it you've got an idea
for a square centimeter looks like
here's another one here's another one
and another one another one if I went
all the way how many would I draw I draw
a hundred of it what am I but that's
only my first row I've got to do a
hundred rows up this way does that make
sense so how many square centimeters are
there in a meter and the answer is if
I'm converting this way from a big unit
to a tiny tiny tiny unit right I'm gonna
multiply by not a hundred even though
there are a hundred centimeters in a
meter there are a hundred times a
hundred
square centimeters in a square meter
does that make sense so you can see this
is actually you can write it like this
if you like it's a hundred square yeah
which means if I'm going that way I'm
going to divide by a hundred squared
okay now there are other parts over here
that you could fill in I mean this would
be hectare right remember we actually
just we just talked about this how many
meters are there sorry how many square
meters are there in a hectare there are
10,000 right which again you divide by a
hundred squared and again this way you
multiply by a hundred square okay now
this is all for area or for area and
that's why these things are squared you
see that I'm not gonna start drawing it
but if I were converting volumes now
you've got this square meter and they're
not only is it flat fee but you've got a
meter coming down this way right how
many little cubes that are one are you
gonna give this space 100 square it'll
be 100 cubed which is 100 and they're
two more zeros and then two more zeros
that's a billion you can fit a billion
cubic centimeters in by single cubic
meter because a cubic meter is a really
big space
so we've just done the length conversion
sort of bubble diagram together I'd like
you to do the area conversion one as
well I've just started for you and I
reckon you guys could do the volume
conversion one off your own back because
you see the pattern okay